joining me now chrissy brown executive
director of mountain area pregnancy
services in asheville north carolina one
of the clinics attacked this week
christie
um
it i mean i saw the way it looked you
know the the photo of the front of the
crisis pregnant pregnancy center that
you work for
my question to you is it's pretty pretty
awful will you be cowed by these
the actions these criminal actions of
the radicals
thank you for having us on laura
although we take this as a direct threat
to our pregnancy center we will not back
down we continue today to provide
services to a full day of clients we
will be there tomorrow providing clients
we just have to make a few alterations
in light of doors being broken and that
type of thing but we will rebuild and
improve and continue doing what we do
and the young women
who come
for
hope and an alternative to abortion i've
had the great privilege of speaking a
lot of uh crisis pregnancy centers
across the country just amazing angels
among us who work at these centers um
but are they are you worried that
they're going to be scared which i think
is part of the
part of the plan here they they don't
want these young women seeking these
services they prefer them to go for the
quickie abortion down the road at
planned parenthood
correct so our first thought this
morning was our clients we had to first
assess if we could even see them when we
realized we could then we got on the
phone and we started calling and we said
here's what happened but we want you to
know you're going to be safe we have
police presence
and our clients came in so it just means
we're having to prep them and we're
going to get the paint off as quickly as
possible get the glass cleaned up as
quickly as possible because we want a
safe environment for clients volunteers
and staff
now an anarchist group and you saw that
the the a with the circle sent a tweet
with a link to a proclamation for jane's
revenge
um in the night of rage it read we need
to get angry we need to express this
madness fully and with ferocity we need
to quit containing ourselves the next
step is carrying that anger out into the
world
and expressing it physically
uh
christy that's about as close as it
comes to a violent threat
again when the road decision ultimately
is handed down by the supreme court
are you going to be taking extra
precautions for your own safety
and the safety of your clinic
well we started last year taking extra
precautions for safety in our center so
we have already put some steps into
place
with today's events we have been
reassessing everything today we do feel
there's a few additional steps that we
are taking we are in constant
communication tonight with our local
police who have been wonderful with us
today and so yes there will probably be
a few additional steps that we need to
take
well i'll just say um christy thank you
for speaking out tonight there are a lot
of folks out there who are truly
frightened by what they're seeing you're
actually saving lives
and they're attacking you for doing that
talk about dark that is truly demonic
thank you so much hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else